The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I'd like to
discuss with you some solution
methods that we employ to
solve the finite element
equations that we encounter in
nonlinear dynamic analysis.
The solution methods that are,
in general used, can be
thought of to fall into these
three categories; direct
integration methods, mode
superposition, and
substructuring.
In this lecture, I would like to
talk about the explicit and
implicit techniques, direct
integration methods, that we
use to solve the finite
element equations.
In the next lecture, we will
talk about the mode
superposition and substructuring
techniques, and
we will also consider
example solutions.
When we want to solve the finite
element equations in
nonlinear dynamic analysis, we
recognize that basically we
have to operate on this
set of equations.
Here we have the inertia forces,
the damping forces,
the elastic forces, and the
externally applied loads.
The inertia forces and damping
forces, well, you know them
quite well.
They're written in terms of
mass matrices, damping
matrices, accelerations,
velocities.
The elastic forces, here
"elastic" in quotes, are
actually the nodal point forces
that are equivalent to
the internal element stresses.
And we talked, in the earlier
lectures, about how we
evaluate them using, in
the updated Lagrangian
formulation, Cauchy stresses.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation, the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses
et cetera.
Please look up all the
information that we talked
about in the earlier lectures,
if you want to study how we
calculate these forces in large
displacement, large
deformation, large
strain analysis.
This set of equations should
hold at any time t during the
response solution.
And in direct integration
analysis, we consider this set
of equations at the discrete
time points delta t apart, as
shown down here.
Of course, even in static
analysis, we always worked
with the data t time
increment.
But in static analysis, we did
not include the inertia
forces, and the damping forces
in the analysis.
The issues that we like to
discuss are, what are the
basic procedures for obtaining
the solutions at
the discrete times?
And then once we have discussed
this question, we
have to address the question of
which procedure should be
used for a given problem.
If we use, so to say a bad
procedure, "bad" in quotes for
a given problem, the costs
can be very high
to solve the problem.
Therefore, it can be important,
can be very
important to select the
appropriate technique for the
given problem.
Let's talk first about the
explicit time integration
techniques.
And the one that I like to
focus attention on is the
central difference method.
The central difference method
is very widely used to solve
nonlinear problems.
It's an explicit technique,
as we will just now see.
The basic equations that
we are working
with are listed here.
This is the equilibrium
equation at time t.
Notice here is a tf, the force
that corresponds to the
internal element stresses
at time t.
Here are the damping forces, and
here the inertia forces.
We expand the velocity at
time t as shown on the
right hand side here.
And we expand the acceleration
at time t as shown on the
right hand side here.
These are the central
difference formulas.
This method is mainly used for
wave propagation problems.
It's an explicit technique,
and this is an important
point, it's an explicit
technique because we are
looking at the equilibrium
equation at time t to
calculate the response for
time t plus delta t.
Any method that does just that,
looks at the equilibrium
equation at time t to obtain the
solution for the response
at time t plus delta t is termed
an explicit method, an
explicit integration method.
So the central difference
method is
such an explicit method.
The important point to recognize
right here is that
we don't set up a k matrix,
a stiffness matrix.
And that is one important
fact that pertains
to an explicit technique.
Using these three equations,
we can
directly develop one equation.
And that equation looks
as shown up here.
Notice we have three equations
and three unknowns
which can be solved.
The three unknowns being the
displacement at time t plus
delta t, the velocity at time
t plus delta t, and the
acceleration at time
t plus delta t.
Three equations and
three unknowns.
We can solve these equations
and the governing equation
that we obtain in that solution
is listed right here.
Notice m over delta t squared.
Notice c over 2 delta t here.
And then the unknown
displacement corresponding to
time t plus delta t, and on the
right hand side, we have
what we call an effective
load vector
corresponding to time t.
There is a hat here, and that
hat means that there are a
large number of terms to
be taken into account.
Namely, those corresponding to
the inertia and the damping in
the system.
Here we have tr hat is equal
to tr, the actual loads
applied corresponding
to a time t.
These are the externally
applied loads
to the nodal points.
tf is the force vector
corresponding to the internal
element stresses, as
I said earlier.
Here we have an inertia
contribution.
Here another inertia
contribution and a damping
contribution.
But it is important to recognize
that the right hand
side is known.
In other words, all the terms
here are known because these
terms only involve displacements
corresponding to
time t minus delta t,
and displacements
corresponding to time t.
And therefore we know this tr
hat, we can plug it in here on
the right hand side and
calculate the unknown
displacements corresponding
to time t plus delta t.
The method is most useful when
m and c, the mass and damping
matrices are diagonal.
Because in that case, these
equations here decouple as
shown right here.
Notice we can calculate the
individual displacements
components, or the displacement
that's individual
degrees of freedom, one after
the other as shown here.
Once we have evaluated tr hat,
tr hat let's remember,
contains these terms here.
In other words, although m and
c are diagonal, there is some
coupling from the equation j
into equation j minus 1 and
into equation j plus 1 right
here on the right hand side,
because the element
contributions overlap the
degrees of freedom.
And therefore, this here is
where the element coupling at
the nodal points enters.
But once we have calculated
this vector here, I should
point to this vector here.
Once we have calculated this
vector, we know the individual
components, then we enter
here with that component
corresponding to a degree of
freedom i, and directly we can
calculate the nodal point
displacements corresponding to
a degree of freedom i.
That's an important point to
recognize, that there is no
need really to set
up a k matrix, to
trianglize a k matrix.
We don't do that here, and that
means that per time step,
this solution method can
be very effective.
Note that in the solution if
the damping is 0, in other
words, we don't have damping in
the system, cii is equal to
0, we need that mii
is greater than 0.
Otherwise we can't solve
the equations.
Notice that tf is calculated
by summing all the element
contributions.
Summing over m means summing
over all the elements.
And as I mentioned earlier, this
is where coupling comes
into the solution because one
nodal point, one degree of
freedom at that nodal point
carries contribution from all
the elements that surround
that nodal point.
To start the solution, we need
a special equation because,
remember in the solution for
time t plus delta t, we need
the information, the
displacements corresponding to
time t, and corresponding
to time t minus delta t.
So, if t is equal to 0, and we
want to march ahead to delta
t, in the first step--
we are in the first step--
we use this equation to
calculate, to evaluate
minus delta tu.
And that means we can then
directly start our explicit
solution process.
The central difference method is
only conditionally stable.
The condition that has to be
satisfied on the time step is
given in this equation.
Delta t critical is a critical
time step, and delta t, the
actual time step that is used
in the solution, has to be
smaller than that value.
Smaller or equal
to that value.
Notice delta t critical is given
as tn over pi, where tn
is the smallest period in the
finite element assemblage.
In nonlinear analysis, we have
to recognize that tn changes
during the time history.
Response, tn would become
smaller if the system
stiffens, due for example to
large displacement effects.
And tn would become larger if
the system softens due to
elasto-plasticity effects.
One interesting and most
important point is that tn can
be estimated.
And it can be estimated, or we
can find a bound on tn which
we can then use to calculate
the critical time step.
And that is achieved
as follows.
We notice that the omega n
squared, omega n being 2 pi
over tn radians per second omega
n squared is smaller or
equal to the maximum of the
omega m, nms squared over all
elements m.
Now what does this mean?
It means here that we're looking
at omega nm squared of
each of the elements, and we
select the largest such value
to put in here.
And that then gives us an upper
bound on omega n squared.
The actual omega n that
we need, because
omega n gives us tn.
So we want to calculate the the
largest frequency of all
individual elements.
And with that largest frequency,
we enter in this
equation here, to get the bound
on tn, noting that in
nonlinear analysis omega nm
changes, just the way I said
earlier tn will also change.
But all the omega nm changes
and tn correspondingly
changes, this equation
is always satisfied.
The time integration step that
we can actually use then, is
given by as this equation.
We can use delta t is equal to
2 over omega nm maximum.
The maximum radiant per second
frequency that we have for any
one of the elements in
the complete mesh.
Because that expression is
smaller or equal than the
critical time step.
We could call this value here 2
over omega nm , the critical
time step of element m.
And therefore, what we're doing
here really is, that
we're taking the smallest of the
critical time steps over
all elements as that time
step in the solution.
And that time step we
know is smaller or
equal to delta t critical.
Let's look at the proof of this
relationship, because
it's an interesting proof and it
gives us a bit more insight
into why this relationship
really holds.
So I'd like to prove to you
very briefly that this
relationship here is valid.
And we do so by using the
Rayleigh quotient.
Please look at the textbook
where the Rayleigh quotient is
discussed, and I have to now
assume that you are familiar
with the Rayleigh quotient.
If you write down the Rayleigh
quotient for omega n squared,
it is this relationship here.
Omega n being the largest
frequency of the complete
finite element mesh.
Omega n is equal to 2
pi divided by tn.
And tn was the smallest period
in the mesh that we are
interested in knowing.
Let us define this relationship
here, just the
definition, and this
relationship here.
Once again, just
the definition.
Then, by simply substituting
from here and there into this
relationship here, we surely
can write this equation as
shown here.
We're summing over all of the
us, and we're summing
over all of the is.
m going over all the elements.
If you have a 1,000 elements in
the mesh, then n would go
from 1 to 1,000.
If we now look at the Rayleigh
quotient for a single element,
we can say that rho m is given
by this relationship.
Which is nothing else, using our
definition of um and im,
is nothing else than this
relationship here.
However, we can immediately
recognize that rho m, this
value here, must be smaller or
equal to omega nm squared,
where omega nm is the largest
frequency radian per second of
the element m.
This is here a relationship
that must hold because the
Rayleigh quotient statement,
or the Rayleigh quotient
theorem, tells us that
this must hold.
And once again, please look up
in the textbook a general
proof, there's a general proof
given that in fact this is a
valid statement.
Where now we can use this
statement, go back to this
equation and immediately
identify that this must hold.
And notice once again I'm
looking here at the element m.
Of course, this relationship
must hold for all elements, m
going from 1 to the total
number of elements you
actually have in the mesh.
This is the relationship we
will be using, and we
substitute that relationship in
our earlier expression, for
the omega n squared and directly
arrive at this
relationship here.
Now we look at this part here,
and recognize that we can take
this out of the summation sign
by using the largest or the
effect, we can take the effect
out of the summation sign, I
should've said, by taking
the largest
value of omega nm squared.
And that's being done here and
now we can cancel these two
terms resulting into this
relationship which
completes our proof.
It's an interesting proof, and
once again if you're not
familiar with the Rayleigh
quotient, please look up the
information in the textbook,
after which I think you can
quite easily follow
this proof.
The important point now is that
the largest frequencies
of simple elements can be
estimated analytically.
Sometimes we can calculate them
exactly, and here we have
a case where we can calculate
the largest frequency of the
element exactly.
Here we have a two nodal truss
element, m here, m here, equal
to rho AL over 2.
L being the length of the
truss, A being the cross
sectional area, rho being
the mass density.
If we write down the eigenvalue
problem for this
single element, we obtain
this relationship here.
Stiffness matrix times the
eigenvector phi omega squared,
which will be an eigenvalue, the
mass matrix phi being the
sought eigenvector.
And if we solve this eigenvalue
problem, we obtain
directly as the eigenvalues
these two values here.
There are only two of course,
because this is
a two by two matrix.
And so is that.
So we have only two
eigenvalues.
The first eigenvalue is 0, the
rigid body mode in the system.
And the second eigenvalue is
given here, which is equal to
omega n squared.
And there is the relationship
of that second eigenvalue
obtained by some very simple
calculations, and this is a
rewriting of that equation,
of that relationship here.
c is a wave speed
in the system.
In fact, c squared is, as you
can see here, e over rho.
It's this relationship that
we can now use, very
conveniently, to get a time step
in a finite element mesh
that will satisfy the critical
time step criterion.
In other words, if we have a
finite element mesh that is
consisting of an assemblage of
such truss elements, then to
get the time step for the
explicit time integration,
which will be a good time step,
which will be smaller or
equal to the critical time step,
what we do is we simply
calculate this relationship here
for each of the elements.
And this relationship will give
us then, the proper time
step by evaluating the smallest
time step that we can
use for any one of
the elements.
In other words, we simply take
2 over omega n, which is
written here, and we recognize
that L over c, where L is the
length of the element, is the
time step that we can use in
the analysis.
Notice L over c, we want to use
the smallest value of L
over c coming from all
of the elements.
L would be an element length.
c would be the wave speed
through the element, and we
want to use the smallest value
of L over c, looking at all
the elements, as the time step
for our time integration.
Notice here that L over c is
the time required for wave
front to travel through
the element.
That is a physical
interpretation of
this L over c value.
Let's look at some
modelling aspects
regarding this technique.
Let the applied wavelengths
be Lw as shown here.
Here schematically
we show a wave.
And let's see that how we would
model the finite element
system appropriately when
we apply to that system
this kind of wave.
Well, we first of all find the
value tw, which is really the
time required for the total
wave to propagate across a
particular point in
the mesh, with the
wave speed c of course.
We then choose delta t via this
relationship here, where
n is the number of time steps
used to represent the wave.
With delta t now known, we
directly get Le, which is the
element lengths.
Well, I should not quite say
it's the element lengths, it's
related to the element
lengths.
For very simple problems, and
particular for our problems in
a model using truss elements,
two nodal truss elements,
actually Le would be the
element lengths.
But if we have more complex
elements to model the finite
elements solution, then this
here, this Le value, would be
related to the element
lengths.
Note that in this formula here,
n has to be chosen by
the analyst to be a reasonable
value so as to be able to
represent the total wave
appropriately.
Here we have some
observations.
Note that in 1D analysis, c,
the wave speed, is given as
the square root out
of e over rho.
I mentioned that already
earlier.
Notice that in nonlinear
analysis, delta t must satisfy
the stability limit throughout
the solution.
This is a very important point
and in the next lecture we
will look at some examples that
demonstrates what happens
if you don't satisfy
the stability limit
throughout the solution.
It may also be effective to
change the time step during
the analysis.
Of course, this you
would do in a
nonlinear analysis, typically.
For the application.
or for the use of the explicit
time integration method, when
you use the explicit time
integration method, one
generally uses lower-order
elements.
They are usually preferable.
And in this particular case,
you want to have
Le here and Le there.
Uniform meshing, uniform
meshing.
For higher-order elements, you
could also use the explicit
time integration.
And there again, you want to
really have that this L is
equal to that L star.
If you don't have that
condition, then this L here
will govern the actual
time step.
The smallest length through
the element will
govern the time step.
And if you use this value here
for Le, with 8 there, you have
a conservative value for Le.
This 8 here enters into the
solution because you have this
midnode, and the midnode carries
more stiffness then
the corner nodes.
Let us look further at
some observations
regarding the method.
In the analysis of this problem,
where we have a beam
subjected to an end step load as
shown here, we can get the
exact solution by simply
choosing a finite element mesh
of truss elements that satisfy
this relationship here.
In other words, we represent
this beam here, using two
nodal truss elements.
And these two nodal truss
elements have a length equal
to c times delta t.
Of course, we're looking here at
a linear elastic solution,
meaning that c is constant.
And we will get, this is the
important point, we will get
the exact solution for
any number of truss
elements that are used.
In fact, we will look at this
problem later on in the next
lecture in more detail, and we
will use this fact to obtain
the exact solution, and we'll
study also what happens if we
change the time step.
So I'd like to refer you to the
next lecture in which I
will be talking more
about this problem.
Using the explicit time
integration method, it is very
important to use uniform
meshing.
And the reason for it
is given right here.
Namely, we want to have then a
time step that is not unduly
small in any region
of the total mesh.
If you don't use uniform
meshing, then the time step is
governed by a particular part
in the mesh, the time step
size I should say,
is governed by a
particular part in the mesh.
Namely, those elements which
have the smallest Le, the way
I talked about it earlier.
And that same time step would
be used for the whole mesh,
which means then, that time
step, that small time step
would actually be too
small for the other
parts of the mesh.
Of course, one could say, well,
why not use different
time steps in the mesh?
Namely, effective time steps for
the elements that are used
in the various regions
of the mesh.
That can be done, but then you
have to use special coupling
techniques to couple the time
step integrations where you
use in one mesh a small time
step, in one part of the mesh
a small time step, in the other
products the mesh a
larger time step.
It can be done, but it needs
special considerations
regarding the coupling of the
time integrations in the
different parts of the mesh.
We may also want to note that
a system with a very large
bandwidth can be solved
frequently, quite efficiently,
with the central difference
method, although the problem
may not be a wave propagation
problem.
The reason for this fact is
that in the explicit time
integration, you do not set up a
k matrix, and therefore, the
large bandwidth that you're
seeing in the k matrix is not
really a hindrance.
It is not being used because the
k matrix is not being set
up, and you have no
factorization or LDL transpose
factorization of the
coefficient matrix.
And therefore, this high cost
that lies in the factorization
of the coefficient matrix is not
necessary, is not used, is
not expensed in the explicit
time integration.
And for that reason, it can be
effective to use explicit time
integration when there would
be such a large bandwidth.
Explicit time integration lends
itself also very well to
parallel processing.
Notice that the basic equations
that we are solving
for in explicit time
integration, in each time step
are given as here.
T plus delta tu is equal to
something that I denote here
by the three dots,
times tr hat.
And this tr hat vector
we defined earlier.
So all we need to do is
calculate these entries in the
vector here to get our unknown
displacements.
Well, that can be done quite
effectively in parallel.
We might want to calculate these
entries here at the same
time as we calculate
say, these entries.
Where this is here a particular
element group, and
that are the entries
corresponding to an adjacent
element group.
And these are the entries
corresponding to another
element group.
So we can, in other words, in
parallel, process all the
information that goes in here,
that goes in here, and that
goes in here, and so on.
Notice there's some coupling
in that information, which
goes across this red
horizontal line.
That coupling comes from the fm
contributions, namely the
element contributions that
will be elements that lie
across these equations,
so to say.
And that's where a coupling
lies, and that has to be
properly taken into account in
the parallel processing.
But in principle, explicit time
integration because the
equation that we are dealing
with, as shown here, lends
itself very well to parallel
processing on computers.
Let us now look at the other
technique that I wanted to
discuss with you briefly
in this lecture.
And this is an implicit time
integration method.
It is a trapezoidal rule, which
is very widely used in
implicit time integration.
But let's first look at the
basic equation that we now are
operating on.
In implicit time integration,
in any implicit time
integration scheme, we are
solving this equation here.
At time t plus delta t to obtain
the solution at time t
plus delta t.
Notice this is the equilibrium
equation at time
t plus delta t.
This is quite different from
what we're doing in explicit
time integration.
In explicit time integration
we are looking at the
equilibrium equation at time t
to obtain the solution at time
t plus delta t.
Here we are looking at the
equilibrium equation, we are
using the equilibrium equation
at time t plus delta t to
obtain the solution at
time t plus delta t.
And that means that we have to
deal with a stiffness matrix.
And that stiffness matrix here
is given as tk, corresponding
to a modified Newton
iteration.
Notice that this equation will
be solved to calculate an
increment and displacement.
And that increment in
displacement is added to the
displacement vector that we
had from the previous
iteration to obtain an updated
displacement vector.
This is one equation in the
unknown displacements,
velocities, and accelerations
at time t plus delta t.
And we need two more
equations to solve
for these three unknowns.
In the trapezoidal rule, which
as I mentioned just now, is
very widely used for implicit
time integration, these are
the basic equations used for
displacements and for
velocities.
If we rewrite these equations,
we directly obtain the
velocities and accelerations
in this form.
Notice there is here the
increment in displacement from
time t to time t plus delta t.
Similarly here.
In nonlinear analysis, we
are iterating for this
displacement here, and therefore
we rewrite these
equations a bit.
And that's being shown,
that rewriting is
shown on this viewgraph.
Notice that we now have
the superscript k here
corresponding to the iteration
k, and that we have split the
displacement at time t plus
delta t into a value that we
know, corresponding to iteration
k minus 1, and an
increment that is unknown,
delta uk.
We do the same for the
acceleration here.
Of course, these terms
are as shown on
the previous viewgraph.
And now we have our velocity and
acceleration corresponding
to iteration k, in terms of
known values and one unknown
value, the incremental
displacement.
We can now use these two
equations and substitute into
our equilibrium equation the
equation that you saw on the
first viewgraph, when we started
to talk about the
implicit time integration
scheme.
And the result of that
substitution is
given on this viewgraph.
We have a coefficient matrix
here, which we call tk hat
times the incremental
displacement
vector, which is unknown.
And on the right hand side of
that equation, we have the
externally applied loads,
the nodal point forces
corresponding to the internal
element stresses at time t
plus delta t, and at the end
of iteration k minus one.
To evaluate these, we need the
displacements corresponding to
iteration k minus 1.
And here we have inertia
contributions and damping
contributions.
But notice all this information
here is known once
you know the displacements
corresponding to t plus delta
tu k minus 1.
We iterate on this equation
until we satisfy certain
equilibrium criteria,
convergence criteria, and much
the same way as we do it in
static nonlinear analysis, and
the way we discussed it
in an earlier lecture.
However, let us make
a few observations.
First of all, we notice that as
delta t gets smaller, the
entries in this tk hat matrix,
this effective stiffness
matrix, increase.
Why do they increase?
Because we have delta t squared
term, 1 over delta t
squared term in front
of the mass matrix.
And the 1 over 2 delta
t term in front
of the damping matrix.
As delta t becomes smaller, 1
over delta t squared becomes
larger and that means that the
entries in this matrix here
become larger as delta
t gets smaller.
The convergence characteristics
of the
equilibrium iterations
are better
than in static analysis.
The reason being, that the
entries in tk hat are
generally larger, much larger
than what we see in static
analysis because of this 1 over
delta t squared term, and
1 over 2 delta t term, that
I just mentioned.
We also notice that the
trapezoidal rule is
unconditionally stable
in linear analysis.
The analysis that shows that the
method is unconditionally
stable is really performed on a
linear system, and therefore
the unconditional stability
strictly
holds only linear analysis.
For nonlinear analysis, we want
to select delta t for
accuracy, and we want to select
delta t for convergence
of the iteration.
If we find, for example, that
we have convergence
difficulties in the iteration,
then we may want to switch to
a more powerful scheme.
That's one approach, of course,
just the same way as
we are doing it in
static analysis.
Or we may also recall, or we
may identify actually, that
delta t is too large, and we
should decrease delta t.
In particular, as a rule of
thumb, I'd just like to share
some experience with you.
We find that if you use the
BFGS method, which we
discussed earlier in an earlier
lecture, if you use
the BFGS method for the
equilibrium iteration, and if
we have difficulties converging
there, then very
frequently the time
step is too large,
and should be decreased.
Not just to obtain convergence
in the BFGS iterations, but to
obtain an appropriate
accuracy.
So we really look at the
difficulties obtaining
convergence in the iterations as
also a signal to us to tell
us that our time step delta
t is probably too large.
The convergence criteria that we
are using are basically the
same that we have seen already
in the static analysis in an
earlier lecture.
In static analysis we only
included this term here.
In dynamic analysis we include
now the mass and damping terms
in our energy criterion.
We discussed this criterion
earlier, of course not
including the mass and
damping effects.
Now we do.
Another convergence criterion is
one on forces, and earlier
we had only this term here.
Now we include also the inertia
and the damping terms.
Once again, if we are only
having translational degrees
of freedom, then here we have
only nodal point forces, nodal
point forces here.
And our norm would be having
the dimensions of a nodal
point force.
If we have rotational degrees
of freedom, then we still
include here only the
nodal point forces.
We extract, in other words, the
components corresponding
to the translational degrees of
freedom of this vector and
that vector, and include those
components only up here.
We use RNORM that also has the
units of the nodal point
force, and we supplement this
convergence criteria by
another quotient, where we have
on top the components
corresponding to the rotational
degrees of freedom
only, and in the bottom,
what we called
RMNORM already earlier.
The point is that we want to
have up here only those
components that carry the same
units as we have down here.
Once for translations,
once for rotations.
And of course recall we're
talking here about the
Euclidean norm.
which is defined
as shown here.
We went through this already
earlier, when we talked about
the convergence criteria
in static analysis.
We have also the convergence
criterion on displacements.
Notice this is what
we saw already
earlier in static analysis.
Once again, we use displacement
components here
to compare with the
displacement.
We introduced all of the
displacement components here
to compare with this
displacement and if we have
rotational degrees of
freedom, they would
not be included here.
Their components would
When you use DNORM here, they
would, however, in a second
check be included here and only
included here, and then
we would use here DMNORM.
We went through that
earlier already.
Some modelling hints regarding
the use of the implicit time
integration scheme.
The integration scheme is
generally used to analyze
structural vibration
problems, and we
would proceed as follows.
We identify the frequencies
contained in the loading by a
Fourier decomposition.
We chose a finite element mesh
that can accurately represent
the static response and all
important frequencies.
And then we perform a direct
integration using this time
step here where tco is the
smallest period in seconds
that we want to integrate.
Now there's a lot of information
here, and I'd like
to refer you to an example,
analysis of a tower that I
will be presenting to you in
the next lecture, where we
will talk about these items
quite a bit more.
But this is basically the
approach that we use, to model
the problem and then also to
perform the direct integration
of the governing finite
element equations.
As I said earlier already, the
method is used primarily for
structural vibration problems.
It is effective, quite
effective, using also
higher-order elements.
And if we do use higher-order
elements, we do find
frequently that method, or the
total solution should be
performed most effectively
using a
consistent mass matrix.
I'm thinking here in particular,
if you use very
high-order elements such as
cubic shall elements,
isoparametric cubic shell
elements, an element that we
will talk about in a later
lecture, then with such
element you probably want to use
a consistent mass matrix
for the overall solution
of the problem.
Notice that a structural
vibration problem can be
thought of as a static problem
including inertia forces.
And we already have noted that
in structural analysis of
static problems, the
higher-order elements do quite
well, and sometimes much better
than the lower elements.
And for this reason, they also
do quite well in dynamic
analysis of structural
vibration problems.
A typical problem that one might
like to solve using this
implicit time integration
scheme, is
schematically shown here.
We have a tower that is
subjected to a blast loading
as shown here schematically,
and we assume that only the
structural vibrations
of this tower are
required to be solved.
In this case, we may very well
obtain the response of the
tower using something like about
100 steps to integrate
the response.
In fact, we will look at a
problem of this nature in the
next lecture, where we do
actually analyze a tower using
the implicit time integration
scheme.
And where we talk a little bit
about how the tower would be
modelled, and what one would
look for to make sure that you
have adequately calculated
the response.
Finally, I'd like to also
point out that it can be
effective to use the combined
technique of explicit and
implicit integration.
You might, for example, have a
problem that shows an initial
wave propagation and then
a structural vibration.
In this case, you might first
want to use the explicit time
integration to calculate the
initial wave propagation
response of the structure, and
then restart to use an
implicit time integration
technique to calculate the
vibrational response
of the structure.
So in that case, you would
basically combine explicit and
implicit time integration, but
the combination would be first
explicit, and then implicit
time integration.
Another kind of combination is
quite effective when you have
to analyze problems where you
have very stiff regions and
very flexible regions.
For the flexible regions of the
problem, you might want to
use explicit time integration,
and for the stiff region you
might want to use implicit
time integration.
A typical analysis, for example,
would be a fluid
structure problem, where the
fluid is very soft and the
structure is very stiff.
Using the implicit time
integration for the structure
and the explicit time
integration for the fluid can
be effective.
Of course, then you would also
have to couple these time
integration schemes properly
at the boundary between the
fluid and the structure.
This brings me then to the end
of what I wanted to say in
this lecture.
In the next lecture we will
continue our discussion of
solution methods for the
solution of the nonlinear
dynamic equilibrium equations.
And we will also show examples,
examples that
demonstrate how the techniques
that I discussed in this
lecture are used to
solve problems.
Thank you very much for
your attention.